- Don't freak out about
Trump's classified documents,
because when the President
does it, it's not a crime.
- If the president does
it, then it is not illegal.
- Where have I heard that before?
- Well, when the president does it,
that means that it is not illegal.
- Or the FBI planted the documents,
or Trump declassified
all of the documents.
He just didn't tell anyone.
Like so much spaghetti,
the Trump world is throwing
all kinds of defenses against the wall,
but do any of them stick?
So, today, we're gonna talk about
the various, completely coherent,
and not at all mutually exclusive defenses
that former President Trump is asserting,
and we're also gonna talk about
three big recent developments,
namely that Trump's legal team,
after two weeks of doing
nothing, has now done something
in the form of a horribly written motion
for a special master.
Additionally, one of Trump's friends
released a letter from NARA.
Why he thought this was a good idea
for the former president is beyond me,
and finally the magistrate
judge has agreed to unseal
part of the probable cause affidavit
that gave rise to the search warrant.
Now, one of Trump's defenses
for having government
records and documents
containing alleged national secrets
and nuclear weapons related
information at Mar-a-Lago
is that he had a standing
order to immediately declassify
any material brought into
the White House residence,
and then later removed to Mar-a-Lago.
Now, this is not a particularly
good defense to prosecution
under the three laws cited
in the search warrant
that we know of,
because none of those offenses
depend on the material
being classified itself.
For example, 18 USC 1519 outlines
the federal crime of
obstruction of justice
for destroying, altering, or
falsifying government records.
It's illegal to mutilate,
conceal, or alter, quote,
"any record, document,
or tangible object,"
if the act is done with the intent to
impede, obstruct, or
influence an investigation.
It doesn't matter if
the material itself was classified or not.
The only thing that the
government has to show is that
someone was destroying or
altering any tangible object
for the purpose of
obstructing an investigation,
but, nonetheless, let's
look into the claim that
Trump had a secret standing
order to declassify records.
Rick Grenell, Trump's national
security director, said that,
quote, "There is this phony idea
that he must provide notification
for declassification,
but that's just silly.
Who is he supposed to notify?"
Well, the answer is
he's supposed to notify
the American people and
members of the administration.
When something is declassified,
that means the public is
allowed to see the information.
The declassification system
isn't about the president's convenience.
Glenn Gerstell,
the top lawyer for the
National Security Agency
from 2015 to 2020, called
Trump's claim preposterous.
He said that the information
should be logged,
so it could be identified.
He also said that Trump should notify
the federal agencies
that use those documents,
but Trump's power as commander-in-chief
gave him broad authority
to declassify records,
but Trump didn't wield his
power to declassify records
in the way that past presidents did,
which is probably why we
keep hearing new theories
about how he might have
declassified information.
We can learn a lot by looking at
what his predecessor did
with classified information.
President Obama issued
Executive Order 13526
on December 29th, 2009.
Obama's order created a
National Declassification Center
with a mission to declassify
government materials
and make them available to the public.
To that end, the Obama
order established that
no records may remain
classified indefinitely
in an attempt to increase
government transparency.
The order also provides deadlines
for declassifying information
exempted from automatic
declassification at 25 years.
The National Declassification Center
is part of the National Archives.
Now, Trump did not rescind
Obama's executive order,
and that means that government departments
are still following its procedures.
Trump himself was probably not obligated
to follow this order when
declassifying records,
although some lawyers have argued that
Trump was legally required to
follow the order or rescind it.
Now, courts have never
had to decide this issue
because presidents who don't agree with
their predecessor's orders
simply rescind them and issue new ones,
but, the argument goes,
because Trump was president
and had plenary powers
to declassify things,
he could just declassify
documents without telling anyone.
Oh, yes, the Vulcan mind declassification.
- I know what you know.
- Now, during his administration,
Trump asserted that he
could declassify records
by word, tweet, or thought.
For example, on October 6th,
2020, Trump tweeted, quote,
"I have fully authorized
the total declassification
of any and all documents pertaining to
the single greatest political
crime in American history,
the Russia hoax.
Likewise, the Hillary Clinton
email scandal. No redactions!"
Exclamation point.
Now, news organizations rushed to obtain
the apparently declassified documents,
but the Trump White House denied that
the president had the authority
to declassify records by tweet
without following protocol.
White House chief of staff
Mark Meadows said that
Trump's tweets about
declassifying documents
related to the Russia
investigation were not an order
to declassify or release
further documents.
He filed a sworn
declaration stating, quote,
"The President indicated to me that
his statements on Twitter
were not self-executing
declassification orders
and do not require the
declassification or release
of any particular documents."
Trump's defenders claim that
he declassified material
simply by speaking the words aloud,
and that the real problem is that
other people didn't follow
the appropriate processes
after Trump spoke.
Former Pentagon employee Kashyap Patel
said that he was in the room
when Trump said that they were
declassifying information.
Patel then threw White
House lawyers under the bus.
Quote, "White House counsel
failed to generate the paperwork
to change the classification markings,
but that doesn't mean the
information wasn't declassified."
Now, when a document is declassified,
it's stamped with the word "declassified"
and the date that the
records were declassified.
If that didn't happen,
the records haven't been declassified,
or at least they must be
treated as still classified.
Now, none of that has
stopped Trump's defenders
from claiming that Trump's
declassification powers
were so broad
that he could actually
declassify stuff with his mind.
A spokesperson for the Heritage
Foundation said, quote,
"There's a rich debate about
whether or non a document is declassified
if the president has decided,
but not communicated it
outside of his own head."
Now, maybe there is a debate
at the Heritage Foundation,
but that defense would probably
not work in a court of law
to suggest that the president's thoughts
have the power of law.
Now, bottom line, if the
allegedly declassified documents
weren't modified to state that
they had been declassified,
then they hadn't been declassified.
Now, Trump's defenders
have also claimed that
the president can't break any laws
because the president is
literally above the law
when it comes to this situation.
Fox News laid out this theory succinctly.
- Famously, President Nixon said,
"If the president does it,
then it is not illegal."
- Ah, yes, Richard Nixon,
famously accurate arbiter of legality.
Now, here's the backstory
to this particular claim.
In a series of interviews
with the BBC's David Frost,
former president Richard Nixon
argues that the constitution
allows the president to break the law.
When Frost pressed Nixon
on authorizing the burglary
of the Watergate Hotel,
which he knew was illegal, Nixon said-
- [Nixon] Well, when
the president does it,
that means that it is not illegal.
- [Frost] By definition?
- [Nixon] Exactly.
Then the president's
decision in that instance
is one that enables those who carry it out
to carry it out without violating a law.
- Nixon and Trump shared a
theory of the unitarian executive
that placed no limits on
the president's power.
Trump claimed that, as president,
the constitution vested
him with total authority.
- Then I have an article too
where I have the right to do
whatever I want as president,
but I don't even talk about that.
- The unitary executive was originally
a limited thesis about
the president's power
to remove upper-level
executive branch officials,
but, over many years, the
theory has expanded in scope.
Presidents invoke the
unitary executive theory
whenever they want more expansive power,
but in 2020, the Supreme
Court ruled against
Trump's version of the
unitary executive theory
in a case where he
challenged New York's right
to subpoena Trump and
the Trump organization
for alleged financial crimes.
In Trump v. Vance, the court
rejected the proposition that
a sitting president can use their powers
under Article 2 of the constitution
to assert immunity from
criminal investigation.
The majority opinion also
rejected Trump's alternate theory
that prosecutors should make
a heightened showing of need
before issuing a subpoena
to the president.
Then, in Trump versus Mazars,
the Supreme Court ruled that
the president wasn't immune
from congressional subpoenas.
Now, in Mazars, the court ruled that
Congress had not established a purpose
for demanding the Trump records,
while, in Vance, the court ordered Trump
to respond to the subpoena for
the same financial records.
However, both of these cases
rejected the special needs standard
for issuing a criminal
or congressional subpoena
to a president, and the
Vance and Mazars cases
are in line with the Supreme
Court's other decisions
on the limits of presidential power.
In US v. Nixon, the court ruled that
Richard Nixon had to turn
over White House records
to a special prosecutor,
and in Clinton v. Jones,
the court also held that the
president can be sued civilly
for private conduct before he took office.
Still, the counterargument is that
the president has plenary authority
over classification and
declassification of documents.
If a sitting president were to decide
to declassify every single record
in the United States government,
the president has that power.
It's just a matter of telling people
and making sure that they
follow the process to do so.
Those such arguments are
probably not gonna help
a former president who is
no longer the president,
but what about the claims of
attorney-client privilege
and executive privilege?
Well, Trump also claims that
the gathered documents are protected
by various kinds of privilege.
He wrote in some sort of tweet-like,
"Oh, great!
It has just been learned that the FBI,
in its now famous raid of Mar-a-Lago,
took boxes of privileged
attorney-client material,
and also executive privilege material,
which they knowingly
should not have taken.
By copy of this truth, I
respectfully request that
these documents be immediately returned to
the location from which they were taken.
Thank you!"
Exclamation point.
So let's say you have a friend sitting in
on a meeting with your lawyer,
or you CC your dad on
an email to your lawyer.
Well, you have then waived
the attorney-client privilege,
and when can that privilege be raised?
Well, when someone makes
a legal demand for things
that involve communications
between a lawyer and a client.
This could be made through
a discovery request during litigation
or through a subpoena for
documents served on a lawyer,
or it could be made by
someone requesting that a
lawyer testify under oath.
The client is the person who
is said to hold the privilege.
That means that the client can waive
the attorney-client
privilege as a defense,
but a lawyer cannot waive the privilege
without the client's consent,
and the person claiming
privilege has the burden of
proving that they are
entitled to that privilege.
Now, here, Trump has been
making a privilege argument
to assert that the FBI took material
that was covered by the
attorney-client privilege,
and it's possible that the
investigators removed documents
that are covered by the privilege.
For example, we know that
the FBI collected and took
some of Trump's passports,
though they did return
that shortly thereafter,
and that's because, when officers
execute a search warrant,
they don't read every page of
every document that they find.
That could take days or
even months or years.
Instead, they quickly identify material
that fits within the warrant's
specifics and then remove it.
Then, a team of lawyers and investigators
go through the material in detail.
The Wall Street Journal reported that
the DOJ has already set up a filter team,
also known as a taint team,
to review the seized materials
before they are viewed by investigators
to determine whether
any of those documents
are indeed protected by
attorney-client privilege.
Now, attorney-client privilege is tricky
when you're talking about
advice that the president
received as president.
Discussions between, say,
the president and the attorney general
are not shielded by the
attorney-client privilege.
The attorney general is
not the president's lawyer.
Many of these relationships
in the executive branch
are effectively between
the office of the president
and the attorneys,
not specifically the president
as a person individually,
which is why things like
executive privilege exists,
which we'll talk about in just a second,
but, by the same token,
presidents do hire lawyers
in their individual capacity,
and that's when attorney-client
privilege would attach.
Think Clinton during the Lewinsky scandal
or Trump and Giuliani.
I mean, I guess.
Did we ever figure out
if he was actually Trump's
individual attorney?
We'll have to get back
to that, but, anyway,
attorney-client privilege
would attach to those communications
between the individual
who is the president
and their individual lawyer,
and also the work product doctrine
would protect documents
created in those relationships,
but if some of the documents
are covered by the
attorney-client privilege,
one would assume that
that is mutually exclusive
to those documents
belonging to the government
and needing to return to
the government as well.
But, in a weird twist,
it's the exact opposite
for the other privilege
that Trump asserts.
Trump also asserts executive privilege
over the taken documents.
He seems to believe that
all of the records taken during the search
were inappropriately removed
on the basis of executive privilege.
Apparently, Trump's theory
of executive privilege is
everything I want to keep secret
is therefore secret in perpetuity forever,
but that has never
matched what the law says.
Most legal scholars conclude that,
since the privilege of executive privilege
attaches to the office of the presidency,
rather than the person who
is occupying that office,
a current president can decide
whether his predecessors
can invoke executive privilege or not.
A former president might be able to
assert executive privilege,
but it would be up to
the current president
to uphold that assertion or not.
The DOJ would probably argue that,
even if some of the documents
seized because the warrant
are covered by executive privilege,
all the documents are legally
property of the government,
but since executive privilege attaches to
the executive branch documents
and specifically the current office holder
of the president of the
United States, it seems like,
if Trump possesses any
executive privilege documents,
then Trump necessarily is in violation of
the statutes that we've talked about.
In other words, if executive
privilege is in play,
which it doesn't seem like it should be,
because Trump isn't in office anymore,
it seems like Trump shouldn't
have any of those documents.
So, claims of executive privilege
might actually be a confession.
- We did what we came here to do.
- Generally, former presidents
do not have a right to
keep documents secret
or take them home from the White House
because of executive privilege.
Executive privilege accrues
to the benefit of the
office of the president.
Some of the issues surrounding
executive privilege
were litigated in a case called
Nixon v. the Administrator
of General Services.
When Richard Nixon resigned,
he left behind millions
of pages of documents
and many audio recordings
of his time in office.
He had an agreement with
the administrator of General Services
to store these materials
near his California home.
This agreement also specified that
Nixon could destroy some of the
materials at his discretion,
but Congress passed the
Presidential Records Act
in part to stop Nixon
from destroying these important records,
and Nixon challenged the
constitutionality of the PRA.
The Supreme Court,
however, upheld the act.
The court held that it was constitutional
to give custody of the materials
to officials who worked
in the executive branch,
and that these materials
could only be released
if that action was not barred
by some applicable executive privilege.
Now, with respect to executive privilege,
the Supreme Court rejected Nixon's claim
that presidential
privilege barred archivists
from scrutinizing the materials.
Nixon raised First Amendment
and privacy concerns
about what was in the
materials from his presidency,
but the court held that
the intrusions into Nixon's
private life were minimal
and any intrusion was outweighed
by a clear public interest
in preserving materials
for legitimate historical
and governmental purposes.
Now, here, Trump seems to be
asserting executive privilege
over the materials that
were stored in Mar-a-Lago,
but Trump probably doesn't have a right
to claim executive privilege
as an ex-president.
That privilege is held
by the current president
per Nixon v. GSA.
In that Nixon case, the
Supreme Court held that, quote,
"Executive privilege is
not for the benefit of
the president as an individual,
but for the benefit of the Republic."
The Supreme Court recognized, quote,
"The presumptive confidentiality
of presidential communications
as a qualified privilege,"
That privilege is necessary
because a president, quote,
"And those who assist him
must be free to explore alternatives
in the process of shaping
policies and making decisions
and to do so in a way
many would be unwilling to
express except privately."
The court concluded
that executive privilege
could hypothetically be
asserted by a former president,
but only as to materials
whose content falls within
the scope of, quote,
"Communications in performance of
a president's responsibilities
of his office,
and made in the process of
shaping policies and making decisions."
So far, no former president
has been able to meet this standard,
since it emphasizes the
materials had to have been made
while the person was president
in the process of making
presidential decisions,
and the same principle
applies to materials created
before the president is
sworn in as president.
Trump's allies tried to enlarge
the scope of executive privilege
so that it applied to the president-elect,
but at least a district
court ruling said that
executive privilege may not be
asserted by a president-elect
over communications made
before he takes office.
So, with the background on
Trump's defenses out of the way,
let's look at the new developments.
The first big development is that
Trump finally filed something in court.
Trump's legal team did not file anything
challenging the search warrant
for two weeks after the search,
and this is really inexcusable.
If law enforcement takes materials
that are protected by
attorney-client privilege
or are a lawyer's work product,
that's an urgent matter.
That should be challenged within days
or even hours of the search.
When Trump's legal team
got around to filing something, however,
they chose to file a motion
to appoint a special master.
Now, that's not a crazy request,
as governed by federal
rule of Civil Procedure 53,
which provides that
the court in which any action is pending
may appoint a special master therein,
and that a reference to a special master
shall be the exception, not the rule.
Now, the traditional role
of the special master
is to hold evidentiary hearings
and make rulings that
will facilitate a trial
in the court where the matter is pending.
They're used to assist the judge
in making discovery rulings,
facilitating settlements,
supervising electronic discovery,
reviewing documents and data
that might be privileged.
Now, a special master in the Trump case
could be appointed to
review all the material
that was removed from Mar-a-Lago
to determine if any of
it is indeed privileged.
That's not unusual for a special master
to be appointed to assist
with that litigation,
but it's not clear what value
that would have for Trump.
He's not really challenging
the warrant itself.
Now, before we get to the
substance of this motion,
I should point out that it's
just terribly, terribly written
in the very basics of the motion.
Trump's lawyers filed
it as a separate case,
which appears to be wrong,
which is why the clerks
docketed it as a complaint,
but it's not a complaint
in the traditional sense.
The motion doesn't include
a statement of facts or any evidence,
and they should have
attached a declaration
or a sworn statement from
Trump or Trump's lawyers
attesting to the facts
that they attest to.
They could have provided
plenty of evidence
to support their case if it exists,
like, for example,
the videotapes of the
FBI searching Mar-a-Lago,
but they just didn't.
It only attaches a couple of exhibits
related to the warrant itself,
and the motion also ignores
some of the DOJ's strongest facts
that Trump's lawyer signed
a sworn statement in June,
claiming that they had
returned all of the documents.
Trump could have filed an affidavit
saying that he personally believed
he had returned all of the
records, or that Christina Bobb
didn't have the authority
to speak for him,
or that he had no idea that
he had to return the documents
or something to refute his
own lawyer's statements,
but, instead, the motion
just quotes commentary
that Trump posted on Truth Social,
but these assertions are not the same as
swearing to facts under
the penalty of perjury,
which is normally what you
would do in a motion like this,
but perhaps the most incredible
thing about this motion is
that it appears to admit that
Trump committed the crimes at issue.
After chronicling the
timeline of the back and forth
between Trump and the government,
and how Trump and his
team did a diligent search
for classified documents
and turned them over,
he then admits that, when
the counterintelligence team
at the DOJ's National Security
Division came back in June,
Trump gave them apparently
more classified documents
that they had withheld before.
The motion, in a truly
spectacular use of passive voice,
states, quote, "Responsive documents
were provided to the FBI agents."
And despite Trump's vague assertions
that he cooperated with the government,
the bottom line is that these
records were sitting in boxes
at the basement of a private club,
and they belonged to NARA,
and Trump wouldn't give them back,
and it looks more and
more like the DOJ and NARA
bent over backwards with Trump
on getting the records back,
and they only applied for a search warrant
when he refused to return
the government property,
and then, of course,
there's Trump's new lawyers.
Trump seems to find himself
in a familiar situation,
hiring new lawyers without much vetting,
and then watching the lawyers
make careless mistakes.
For example, the motion to
appoint a special master
was signed by three lawyers,
a Florida license insurance
lawyer, Lindsay Halligan,
plus Jim Trusty from Washington, DC,
and Evan Corcoran from Baltimore.
Now, in the US, lawyers are licensed
to practice in specific jurisdictions,
so if a lawyer wants to represent a client
in a state where he or
she is not licensed,
they have to file a motion with the court,
asking them to be admitted.
This is a very straightforward process
known as pro hoc vice.
Now, this is a very easy motion.
You basically just fill out a form
and say that you're in good standing
in the places that you practice,
but Trusty and Corcoran failed to do this.
The court rejected their motions
and issued a paperless order
on the docket stating that,
"Local counsel is instructed
to refile the motions
in strict accordance with Local Rule 4(b)
of the Rules Governing
the Admission, Practice,
Peer Review, and Discipline of Attorneys.
A sample motion can be found
on the Court's website."
At that URL.
The motions were denied without prejudice,
but it's really just
really careless mistakes.
But going back to the motion
to appoint a special master,
despite Trump's social media claims
that his team would be filing
a major Fourth amendment motion,
the lawyers did not file a
motion to suppress the warrant,
and the special master
doesn't have the authority
to throw the warrant out,
and since it looks like
Trump's team filed this
in the wrong court,
instead of in the same case
that gave rise to the search warrant,
the new court wasted no time
in responding to the motion.
The judge actually ordered
Trump's team to, quote,
"File a supplement to the Motion
further elaborating on the following.
One, the asserted basis
for the exercise of this
Court's jurisdiction,
whether legal,
equitable/anomalous, or both.
Two, the framework applicable
to the court's jurisdiction.
Three, the precise relief sought,
including any request
for injunctive relief,
pending resolution of the Motion.
Four, the effect, if any,
of the proceeding before
Magistrate Bruce E. Reinhart.
And, five, the status of
the plaintiff's efforts
to perfect service on defendants."
Basically, that's the court's way of being
extremely skeptical that they
filed in the right court,
that this court has any
power to do anything,
and basically suggesting that
they should go back in
front of Magistrate Reinhart
to deal with this particular issue.
Now, the second big development
is that John Solomon,
the man Trump named as his
personal representative
with the National Archives,
released a letter from the
National Archives to Trump.
Now, I'm gonna assume this letter is real,
but, so far, it hasn't been validated,
but, also, I have no idea
why this was released,
because it's incredibly
damaging to Trump's claims.
The archivist quoted the
applicable parts of the Nixon case
to explain why it was
so important for NARA
to have custody of the records.
Quote, "The Supreme
Court specifically noted
that an incumbent president
should not be dependent on happenstance
or the whim of a prior president
when he seeks access to
records of past decisions
that define or channel current
governmental obligations."
And the letter states that
Trump is blocking the National Archives
from taking boxes of
national security information
to the DOJ and to the
Intelligence Community
so that they can assess what information
might have been revealed to third parties.
The letter says that these
officials need to take steps
to mitigate the harms from
mishandling the material.
Essentially, the archivist is saying that
it's urgently important
for government officials
to do a damage assessment,
because some of its intelligence sources
could have been burned by Trump.
The letter tells Trump that
the incumbent president,
Biden, needs the records
and that the DOJ had already
explained all of this to him.
Quote, "There are important
national security interests
in the FBI and others in
the Intelligence Community
getting access to these materials.
According to NARA, among
the materials in the boxes
are over 100 documents with
classification markings,
comprising more than 700 pages.
Some include the highest
levels of classification,
including Special Access
Programs SAP materials.
Access to the materials
is not only necessary
for purposes of our ongoing
criminal investigation,
but the executive branch must also conduct
an assessment of the potential damage
resulting from the apparent manner
in which these materials
were stored and transported
and take any necessary remedial steps.
The National Archives
originally wanted them
by the end of April 2022,
but Trump sent NARA a
letter on April 29th,
informing NARA that, in his opinion,
they were covered by executive privilege.
This delayed the process
for an additional month.
NARA rejected the assertion
of privilege though.
The archivist consulted with
the assistant attorney general
for the Office of Legal
Counsel, which, quote,
"Advised me that there is no precedent
for an assertion of executive privilege
by a former president against
an incumbent president
to prevent the latter
from obtaining from NARA
presidential records belonging
to the federal government
where such records contain information
that is needed for the conduct of
current business of the
incumbent president's office
and that is not otherwise available."
So, assuming this letter is
accurate, it's just insane that
Trump did not turn over
all of the documents
months and months ago,
and then the final development is
that parts of the affidavit
that gave rise to the
search warrant are unsealed.
While the Trump said that he
wanted the affidavit unsealed,
he actually didn't join or do anything
with respect to the motion
to unseal the search warrant,
but despite that, several
news organizations
did move forward with the motion,
and the magistrate judge ruled in favor of
unsealing parts of the
affidavit with redactions.
Quote, "As I ruled from the bench
at the conclusion of the hearing,
I find that, on the present record,
the government has not met its burden of
showing that the entire
affidavit should remain sealed."
Generally, affidavits like these
are not revealed until an
indictment has been filed,
because it could impact an investigation,
but, generally speaking,
there's a presumption of
validity of these affidavits,
but that doesn't mean that
a defendant can't challenge the warrant
if it's based on deliberate
falsehoods or other wrongdoing,
and if a search warrant
is defective or deficient,
a criminal defendant can file a motion
to suppress evidence
from being used at trial,
but since Trump has not
been charged with a crime,
filing a motion to suppress
is not yet an option,
though it might be in the
future. But if you'd like to hear
a better thought-out legal
defense, you should listen to
John Grisham's new legal
thriller, "The Judge's List,"
on today's sponsor, Audible.
It's all about a judge
who's also a serial killer
and uses the law against
his investigators.
His legal arguments
are actually better than Trump's lawyers.
Now, I use Audible almost every day.
It's by far the best source
of audio entertainment.
I listen to audio books when
I'm running, cleaning up,
or when I'm supposed to be
listening to friends and family.
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
all in one place.
If you tried to listen to
everything that's on there,
it would take you three centuries.
Now, as an Audible member,
you'll get one credit every month
that you can use on any title
in the entire premium catalog.
That includes basically
every best seller, new
release, and memoir.
Those titles are yours to keep forever
in your Audible library,
and you also get full access
to their popular Plus catalog,
which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audio books,
original entertainment,
guided fitness and meditation,
sleep tracks, and shows.
All are included with
your Audible membership,
no credits needed, and right now,
Audible's running a special promo.
New Audible members get
a free one-month trial.
You can try it out and see
why everyone loves Audible.
All you have to do is go
to audible.com/legaleagle,
or click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description.
So, right now, for a limited time,
get a free one-month trial of Audible
by clicking on the link
below, and after that,
click on this playlist over
here for more Legal Eagle,
or I'll see you in court.